FELIPE HOFFA: Hello everyone.
I'm Felipe Hoffa from the
Google Cloud platform team,
and today's show is about
BigQuery Python Panda
and how to tie
everything together.
I have with me Collin Sellman
from Pearson, the big education
company, and he has some
very good news about BigQuery
and how it's getting
connected now to Pandas.
We'll have some demos.
So welcome Collin,
thank you for coming.
COLLIN SELLMAN: Thank you
for having me, Felipe.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
You are the director of
data science at Pearson.
COLLIN SELLMAN: I am.
FELIPE HOFFA: Pearson
is not a start up.
COLLIN SELLMAN: It
It actually started in 1844, and
today we are a global education
company, but we also own
the "Financial Times".
A lot of people don't
know that about us.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh,
that's pretty big.
COLLIN SELLMAN: It is.
It is a big company.
FELIPE HOFFA: You're everywhere.
And you are the director
of data science.
COLLIN SELLMAN: Data
science, yes indeed.
And what that is
is specifically I'm
tasked with trying to make our
products better, specifically
for student outcomes.
And so the group that I work
in is the K-12 education group,
and specifically
what we look at is
products that are
used in the classroom.
So it could be a
product that is used
throughout the course
of a year or a semester
by a student that
needs to catch up.
It could be a
product that they're
using just a part of their
normal classroom activities.
And as a data
scientist, my job is
to try to figure out how to
use the data that we collect
from a lot of our users
that use our products,
and both prove that our
products are effective-- so
when a student uses it,
that it's going to give them
some better learning
outcome-- and also
to try to make them better.
And so that's a
very exciting time
to be in education,
because there's
lots of really cool things
that we're able to collect now
that we weren't able to
collect five years ago.
So you can imagine when
it was just textbooks,
textbooks didn't
collect data, and so
you couldn't look at how
students used textbooks
or what pages they focused on.
Now with digital products,
we can do a lot of that.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's great.
So you have sixth
graders everywhere using
different products and they
are interacting with them,
you are collecting data,
you are able to tell
how they're using it,
when the tests are--
COLLIN SELLMAN: Yep,
and our whole job
is to try to make
those products better.
So all the data collected
is all anonymous,
but basically we look
at things like that,
like what do students use,
what do they use in some cases
more than other times.
And in a lot of
cases, we try to look
at how we can sort of prove
that that use is leading
to a good student outcome.
So how can we look at what
a student knew, let's say,
before they start using
one of our products
to what they knew
after they started
using one of our products, and
hopefully we can statistically
show that we're making
a positive impact
to what we call student
efficacy, or the efficacy
of learners and
teachers as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's amazing,
helping our students.
And what are your tools?
How do you do this?
COLLIN SELLMAN: So
me personally, I
happen to really
like Python, and I
was introduced to a library
within Python called Pandas
a few years ago,
which has been great,
because a lot of the problems
that I have as a data scientist
is not sort of doing
the end analysis,
but it's in taking all the data
and putting it into a format
that I need to see.
So how do I group these types
of data by different parameters?
And Python, and
Pandas in particular,
is a really great way
to take source data
from different databases--
sometimes from APIs, sometimes
from CSVs, all sorts
of different ways--
put it into--
traditionally what I
do is look at sort of
a denormalized table
of anonymous students
by some variables,
and then do analysis.
So a lot of group
bys, using Boolean
vectors to sort of
filter out and look
at different
aspects of the data.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
BigQuery is your database?
COLLIN SELLMAN: It is.
And so one of the things
that we were fortunate enough
to do this past summer is
we reached out to the Pandas
community and asked
them if they would
like us to try to contribute
a connector from Pandas
directly to BigQuery.
And so because I had
already been using BigQuery,
and sometimes using the base
API, especially on a desktop,
was a little bit problematic
compared to like a Pandas MySQL
connector, which is
really easy, we decided,
hey, let's try to do this.
And my two sort of
coworkers Jacob and Sean
and I during the summer sort
of worked on this open source
project, which is really
great because the community is
really great, really active.
And in so far, it
seems like people
are interested in seeing how
our sub-module within Pandas
can actually enable
them to connect directly
to BigQuery for both
reads and writes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, so for now
on from version 0.13 Pandas
has native BigQuery support?
COLLIN SELLMAN: It does indeed.
It is an experimental
feature now,
because we're still looking at
sort of proving out some things
and really looking
perhaps in the future
to add some more things
in, but it's definitely
in the 0.13 release.
FELIPE HOFFA: I'm
so glad you started
with this project, the
community [INAUDIBLE].
Can you tell me a little about
why you are using BigQuery?
COLLIN SELLMAN:
Well, it actually
started the history
of how I found out
about BigQuery in
the first place
is I was actually on Twitter
and I was following someone that
was talking about sort of
new database technologies--
and this was several years
ago-- and they tweeted a link
to the Dremel
technical white paper.
And so I started to read
that, and the user persona
that whoever wrote that
used, her name was Alice,
and it was talking about Alice
internally working inside
of Google, and looking
at sort of analyses that
weren't necessarily a
good fit for MapReduce,
or sort of traditional
relational databases.
And when I was reading
that, I was like,
Alice is me, because I'm very
much having this problem,
because I was, at that
time, and still continue
to use Amazon, and MySQL,
and some other things.
But some of the types
of queries that I
was doing with these
big denormalized tables
were in some cases
taking 10 or 15 minutes.
And so that could
take a lot of my time,
especially if I'm doing
exploratory analysis.
And so right after that,
I can't remember exactly
after reading the paper, I heard
that BigQuery was coming out
as sort of productized version
of that Dremel technology.
And so as soon as it
came out, I signed up,
I started playing around
with the first data sets,
and then uploading
some of our data,
and that's sort of where
I started with BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's awesome.
So right now your workflow,
instead of waiting 15 minutes,
20 minutes to get answers,
you're able to get it--
COLLIN SELLMAN:
Well, in seconds,
depending on the query.
But in some cases, I'd
see like a 50 to 100 times
speed up in some of the
queries that I was doing.
I think it's also a
lot less overhead,
in terms of managing the
type of instance I have,
and the size of the disk
and all those sort of things
that I would traditionally
had to do in Amazon.
And so it was simpler from
a lot of different reasons.
And also one of the things
I also like about it is it
has the web UI.
So although there's some
great client for MySQL,
having the web UI makes
it really sort of easy
for me to do work at home,
do work in the office,
on different computers,
and take it and do
whatever I need to do anywhere.
FELIPE HOFFA: By the way,
a small trick for the web
UI if you have been using it
have you used auto complete?
COLLIN SELLMAN: Oh,
I just saw that.
I just saw that recently, and so
that was a very exciting thing,
because when I first started
using it, it didn't have that,
and I kept hitting tab
and nothing would happen.
And so now that that it has
it, it's really exciting.
FELIPE HOFFA: If you are
writing queries on the web UI,
you can press tab
and it will auto
complete the function
names, the data
set names, whatever
you need, you
will have right
there in your hands.
Try it out.
But going back to the
Pandas world-- statistics,
we are doing high
level analyses,
we are learning how to
make the product better.
Can you show me a demo of this?
COLLIN SELLMAN:
Actually, I'm going
to have two of my coworkers,
who are here with me today,
who helped us and really
wrote most of the contribution
that we tried to make to
the community of Pandas,
they're going to give
you two different demos.
One's going to be
more of what we would
call a confirmatory
analysis, and one
is going to be an exploratory
analysis both using Pandas,
using our new read GBQ
method and BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: I'm very excited.
Let's get to a demo.
We'll have a minute or
less with the studio magic
to prepare the demo.
So are you ready now?
COLLIN SELLMAN: I'm ready.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's go.
OK so we are back.
We called in
someone from Pearson
and now with Jacob Schaer
we are going for demo
how they are doing data
science at Pearson.
Hi Jacob.
JACOB SCHAER: Hi,
thanks for having us.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank
you for being here.
You will work with Python,
we'll be working with Pandas,
you have some data
science to show us.
What are you doing?
What are we doing today?
JACOB SCHAER: Correct, so
as Collin said earlier,
we're planning on demoing a bit
of a confirmatory analysis--
that is, using a specific method
to answer a specific question.
And by doing so, we
hope to demonstrate
how we use BigQuery
in our analytics.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's awesome.
And what's the question that
we want confirmation for today?
JACOB SCHAER: So
today we're looking
at student use of
practice assessments.
We're hoping to see
if the questions are
too difficult or too
easy for the students.
FELIPE HOFFA: So have students
everywhere in America, they
are answering questions
on an interactive test?
JACOB SCHAER: Correct, one
of our online platforms.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's awesome.
And now we are able to tell
if the questions are hard,
if they're fair,
if they're easy?
JACOB SCHAER: Right.
So the goal is to
look at the difficulty
and assess whether the tests
are meeting the original goals.
FELIPE HOFFA: How are
you able to tell that?
JACOB SCHAER: So we have
the raw item responses
given by each student,
and we're going
to run a Rasch item
analysis, which
is a simple model for students
taking tests that accounts
for their ability, as
well as the difficulty
of the questions.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can
you show me more?
JACOB SCHAER: Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: Awesome.
JACOB SCHAER: So we're
going to start off
by importing our sub-module.
As we mentioned
before, there's now
the GBQ in version 13 of Pandas.
So typical boilerplate,
we're going to import it
and now we get to start
our query preparation.
The key requirements
for this query
was that we have to have
the first time a student has
seen a question.
This is challenging, because
some students can retake
the test, can
retake the question,
or could even have
seen the question
in a different context.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
you have a big data
set of every time students
have answered the question?
JACOB SCHAER: Correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
with BigQuery you
are filtering out only the first
time they saw that question?
JACOB SCHAER: Where
possible, and that's
where Pandas will come
to help clean this up.
FELIPE HOFFA: Awesome.
JACOB SCHAER: So
what we do is we
select basically the
raw data we need,
the student's anonymous
ID, the question's
ID, if they got it right or
wrong, when it was created,
and when they last
updated the score.
This is coming from a
set of 14 questions that
were part of an assessment
in one of our products--
specifically, this was a
writing for seventh graders.
And we're filtering on whether
it was the first time they'd
seen it within that
assessment and if it
had valid time stamps
and valid status.
FELIPE HOFFA: So that
query runs in seconds.
You get data into Pandas?
JACOB SCHAER: Correct.
So if we save this query in
here and we run it using Pandas,
new read_gbq method.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
see how long it takes.
JACOB SCHAER: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Are you
connected to internet?
JACOB SCHAER: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Awesome.
JACOB SCHAER: So it
took around 10 seconds
to run the entire query
against our data set.
So we have the data, we still
have the issue of potentially
retaking the entire
assessment to deal with,
and we can do that using Pandas.
So Pandas has a method,
drop duplicates,
which keeps the first
occurrence of any pair or n
number of columns.
So we're going to do that.
We want to take only
the first occurrence
of any pair of student
IDs and item IDs.
So we drop the
duplicates, and this
is the subset of
what the data is.
Where you can see we
have the student ID,
the question they
took, and whether they
got it right or wrong.
Now we need to pivot the data.
The goal is to have
it in a matrix format.
So the goal is to have
it in a data structure
where the student's
ID is on the rows,
the columns are the question
ID, and whether they
got it right or
wrong is the cells.
FELIPE HOFFA: I see.
And you are going to
do that with Pandas?
JACOB SCHAER: Correct.
There is a way to
do it with BigQuery,
and that is in
the documentation,
but we're going the
demo it with Pandas.
So we can do that with
the pivot method that
comes in Pandas on data frames.
We specify the
index, the item ID,
and the value we'd like
in the cells, we run that,
and we take a preview at it.
So we can see it's generally
in the form we want it now.
As we described, we have
it students as rows,
questions, et cetera, but
there's a problem still,
we still have missing data.
This make sense in this
context, because students
didn't have to finish the tests.
They could have
dropped out early,
they could've had
a session problem.
FELIPE HOFFA: So there are a lot
of blank spaces in the matrix
right now.
JACOB SCHAER: Right.
FELIPE HOFFA: How do
you filter that out?
JACOB SCHAER: Right,
so Pandas again
has a drop N/A method, which
takes out any missing data.
So we basically take
out any students
that didn't complete the test.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's do that.
JACOB SCHAER: And
as you can see,
and all the rows with the
missing data are gone.
FELIPE HOFFA: So now you
have your whole data set,
you filtered it
out with BigQuery,
now you've cleaned
it up with Pandas.
Are you able to
tell me if it was
a hard question or
an easy question?
JACOB SCHAER: Sure.
So for that, we're
going to turn to R.
FELIPE HOFFA: R?
JACOB SCHAER: Yes, new R. It has
a very handy method for this,
the LTM package, for
doing item analysis.
And with the help of the
Rpi 2 Python package,
we can work directly with
R straight from Python.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's so cool.
So right now we are combining
BigQuery, Pandas, R.
JACOB SCHAER: Right, and that's
sort of what Python's good for,
is combining a lot of things.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to import Rpi 2,
and we're going to
load the LTM library.
We're going to perform
the Rasch method that's
contained within the library.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
see what we get.
JACOB SCHAER: So it's
loading the R library,
and we've printed out a few
of the interesting statistics
that it gives us, the
numerical statistics,
such as the
frequency of students
who got a certain number
of questions correct,
the alpha values
for each question,
and the various coefficients
associated with the assessment.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can we get
a visualization of it?
JACOB SCHAER: Right, so
another cool feature about R
is it's really great
graphing functions,
and we can take that
analysis and plot it
very simply in the same way
using the plot methods built
in, and we get a graph that
looks a little bit like this.
FELIPE HOFFA: And what
does that graph mean?
JACOB SCHAER: So this
graph is a comparison
between the students'
ability levels
and their probability of getting
a given question correct.
As you can see, all 14
questions are represented
by line on the graph, and the
key thing to look for here
is the ability level.
So a student with a zero
ability level, in this case,
would be the average
student in the class.
And for that, the
average student
got at least every question
right with 80% probability.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
an amazing [INAUDIBLE],
but I have a
question for Collin.
COLLIN SELLMAN: Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: A
big question we all
have in data science--
how do we transform
these insights into action?
COLLIN SELLMAN: Well, it's
an interesting question.
I think that's really what makes
data science different maybe
from analytics, is that
our goal in data science
is to take an analysis and
build knowledge, and then
do something with it.
And so in this particular case,
when we wrote these items,
we were trying to target a
range of different difficulties.
So you think about a
practice test for students.
You want some items that some
students are sort of earlier
on in their
knowledge can answer,
and some students
that are further along
can answer these
more difficult items.
So ideally, a practice
sort of product like this
has some items that
are more difficult,
some that are sort of
middle of the road,
and some that are easier,
so that every student can
see a little bit of progress.
And so, specifically,
for something
like this, what we've done
is worked with our curriculum
teams, so the teams that are
actually writing these items,
and trying to target
these difficulty levels,
and we loop back with them
and say, here's what we see.
So in this particular case, you
can see that all of the lines
are sort of shifted to the left.
We'd rather see a
distribution of those lines
sort of going between
negative 2 and 2.
And so we're feeding
that information back
into the curriculum team
to say, OK, in this case,
this is what we're actually
seen empirically with this data,
and that's the specific
question that we answered,
and that's how we sort
of improve our products.
And you can imagine if we
didn't do that, we would have,
in this case, a practice
exercise that students
are going through that they
all find very, very easy.
And it wouldn't be accomplishing
our goal, which is basically
to make this practice product
to help them grow and mature
in terms of, in this
particular case,
I think looking at reading
for seventh graders.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK,
that's awesome.
So the curriculum team
is getting real feedback
and real data, all thanks to
the analysis you are doing.
That's amazing.
JACOB SCHAER: Yeah, it was
really useful for the team.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank you, Jacob.
Do we have another
demo coming up?
JACOB SCHAER: Correct.
So Sean is going
to come on and do
a bit of an exploratory
demo for you.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK, let's
have Sean here, then.
Give me a minute, and
we'll be right back.
And we are back with a second
demo, now with Sean Schaefer?
SEAN SCHAEFER:
Yes, hello Felipe.
FELIPE HOFFA: Hello,
thank you for being here.
SEAN SCHAEFER: Hello,
thank you for having me.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
What do you have
to show us today?
SEAN SCHAEFER:
Right, so today I'm
going to be going through a
bit of an exploratory analysis.
FELIPE HOFFA:
Exploratory analysis?
SEAN SCHAEFER:
Exploratory analysis.
So before, Jacob showed more
of a confirmatory analysis,
and that's where he had
a specific hypothesis
that he wanted to see if
his data supported it.
So what I'm going
to do is we're going
to kind of look at the
data without having
any prior assumptions, and
see what kind of conclusions
we can come up with based on
visualization of the data,
in this case.
FELIPE HOFFA: And what's
the data we are looking at?
SEAN SCHAEFER: So
this data is going
to be student answers to
questions on assessments.
So what we're
looking at initially
is just the students
and the questions
that they ended up taking.
And so we're going to visualize
that and see what kind
of relationships we can
see, but the key point here
is that the students
were given choice
in that which questions
they wanted to select.
And so what we're really
trying to look for to see
is there any trends or
any kind of relationships
between the items that
the students selected,
those questions that they
wished to take, and see maybe
what we can take
away from there.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
students today are
able to choose which
questions to answer?
SEAN SCHAEFER: These
are practice tests, yes.
So they, in this specific
case for this product,
they have the choice
of which questions they
feel they would want
to practice the most.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, let's
see what they did.
SEAN SCHAEFER: OK.
So what we're actually
going to use here
is we already have our data
stored in Google BigQuery,
so we're going to use
our GBQ module pull
that data into a
Pandas data frame.
And then we're also going to
utilize another Python library
called Networks, which is going
to allow us to create a network
data structure, which
is just essentially
connections between objects.
So I'll go ahead
and actually run
the code that shows the
network, and then we
can go in and have
a look and see
what it actually looks like.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
see how it works.
SEAN SCHAEFER: OK.
So right now, we have Google
BigQuery actually pulling
the data, and we're
going to be able to see
about how much time that takes
to pull into a Pandas data
frame.
Looks like it took us
about eight seconds.
And now we're going to
have networks take our data
and create a network
graph out of that.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
what's happening now?
SEAN SCHAEFER: So we are
still waiting on the network
to come up.
It actually is a little bit
of computationally expensive,
but we'll be able to visualize
it in just a second here.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you got all the
data from BigQuery filtered out
and now you are processing
everything in your computer?
SEAN SCHAEFER: Correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: With network,
you are getting a--
SEAN SCHAEFER: So now we
have a network graph here.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK.
SEAN SCHAEFER: And
so basically, you'll
see that there are really three
main components to this graph.
We have red circles,
we have blue circles,
and then we seem to have these
black lines between them.
So what the red circles
indicate are students,
and then the blue circles are
the questions that they had
taken , and the lines indicate
the connections between them,
which means that a student chose
to take this specific question.
FELIPE HOFFA: So here we can
see clusters of students.
SEAN SCHAEFER: Yes.
So if you're looking
at this, that's
what stands out most to me.
We have these certain
clusters, and right now we
may not be entirely
sure what that means.
It could be specific
subjects that those students
are trying to study.
What we'll probably want to
do is drill down a little bit
further and see if we can
make any other meaningful
conclusions based on
filtering with the data
that we know we have.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
you have a cluster
of students that like
chemistry, some focus on maths--
SEAN SCHAEFER: Possibly, yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: How can
you go deeper into this?
SEAN SCHAEFER:
Well, we know based
on our data that we have other
things that we've collected.
So another thing
that we've collected
is the time that
it took the student
to answer a specific question.
And so we may want
to look and see
how time is related
to these clusters
and see if we still see
these kind of clusters
if we filter out
for a specific time.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK, let's
add another dimension.
SEAN SCHAEFER: OK, excellent.
FELIPE HOFFA: What do we find?
SEAN SCHAEFER: So first thing
we're going to have to do
is, since in our
initial query we only
were looking at the student
IDs and the questions,
we want to also poll
the time it took
for them to answer
a specific question.
So I'll go ahead and pull
that data from BigQuery
into Pandas using
our GBQ module.
COLLIN SELLMAN: And you asked
me about data science earlier,
this is on the
exploratory side, I've
found that it's
very much like this.
So you start looking at the
data, you see something,
and then it sort of raises
some other questions
that you didn't have before.
And so then you need to re-run
it, add another component
or another feature so
you can look at it.
And so this is where
that being able to do it
very quickly in BigQuery
is a big improvement
in my overall
workflow, especially
dealing with large data sets.
FELIPE HOFFA: You can fit
so many more questions
in one hour.
COLLIN SELLMAN: Yeah.
SEAN SCHAEFER: Exactly.
So it looks like we got our
data into our Pandas data frame,
and let's first just have a look
at the distribution of the time
that we have, so
that maybe we can
see what a good filter would be
based on how long students are,
on average, taking
for these questions.
So one cool thing we can
do with a Pandas data frame
is we can pull one
specific call amount
and plot a histogram
of the values
in that with a very
simple function call.
And so I'll go ahead and
run the code that does that,
and we'll see visually
the different counts
of our distribution of values.
So it looks here like
we have the majority
of the students answering
in under 20 seconds or so.
But we have--
FELIPE HOFFA: Those
are fast students.
SEAN SCHAEFER:
Yeah, so 20 seconds,
you could think maybe an
average amount for a question,
but it actually
looks like we have
a lot of students that are
taking them very quickly.
So in this first
bin, we have students
that are taking
about five seconds.
So that's something
that we might
want to investigate further,
because five seconds
is actually very quick to
answer a specific question.
COLLIN SELLMAN:
Especially the first time
you've seen it, right.
SEAN SCHAEFER: Exactly.
COLLIN SELLMAN: So you take
some time for the question
to come up, for you
to read it, and then
come up with a response.
SEAN SCHAEFER: Right,
so what we can do now
is plot our network once
again, and this time we'll
try and look at what's
going on in those cases
where the students are
taking five seconds or less
to answer the question.
FELIPE HOFFA: The
special kind of student.
SEAN SCHAEFER: Yes.
Maybe.
We aren't quite sure what's
going on yet at this point.
So we can go ahead and
run that query again,
and this time we will add
the filter for five seconds
or less, and we'll build out
our network graph once again.
FELIPE HOFFA: I
love network graph.
Even if I don't
really understand what
this one is doing.
SEAN SCHAEFER: It's
an excellent way
to visualize the relationships
between two specific components
that you have, yes.
Especially if you're
not quite sure what
those relationships
might be yet.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
once you discover
what's happening behind-- how do
you turn this into actionable?
COLLIN SELLMAN: Well, I think
in this particular case,
we're looking at-- I think as
we look at the visualization,
one of things that
we're focused on
is how to make our
programs more effective.
And so when we're looking at
this particular case of looking
at students that took
less than five seconds,
it could be that
they're guessing.
And so the interesting thing
that networks does in addition
to sort of visualizing it
is think about it like sort
of a dictionary or like
a JSON format, where
you can take basically students
and questions are nodes,
and then there's an
edge between them.
So if the student has
taken this question,
there's an edge, we can
add things of that edge,
for example-- did they get it
right, did they get it wrong?
And so if we wanted to look
at the network of students
and items that were taken in
less than five seconds, what
was the proportion that
were correct in that
versus maybe the
students and items that
were taken five to 10 seconds.
So you could imagine
that we can think
about how students
are taking it,
and potentially we could make
our products identify perhaps
when students are guessing,
or maybe change the UI
to talk to students
about, hey, maybe
you should spend a little
bit more time looking
at this question, because
you're more likely to get right.
But the network's
sort of concept
is really interesting,
because you
can add whatever sorts of
attributes that you would like.
So you could add things
like did they get it right,
did they get wrong,
what was the order
that they took those questions?
So again, in this case,
students are allowed choice,
so do they start with the
harder problems in the algebra
section, or do they start with
sort of the more basic skills?
Because our program is sort of
designed around that, and so
we can visualize all
those different things.
In this particular
case, there's not
a specific answer
we're coming up with,
but we're really exploring,
and as we actually did this
this past summer, we found some
very interesting things that
definitely informed the
design of our products
in terms of how we
presented questions
and how we sort of
gauge students feedback
when they got questions
right and wrong.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's so cool.
I'm so excited about this, how
you are collecting data, that's
a completely new
face for education.
You are not having
[INAUDIBLE] books
or having interactive data.
I know you would be
able to collect data
with Google Analytics soon.
COLLIN SELLMAN: That
is one of the things
that we're also looking at.
So we use Google Analytics
quite a bit differently,
because we don't use it for
marketing or sales conversions,
but we use it in some cases to
track usage of our products.
And previous to having
things like Google Analytics,
we might have done
a field study where
we partner with the school
and we have researchers
in the field, in the
school, observing
how teachers and
students use that.
And so we continue to
do that, but imagine
taking Google Analytics usage
data for those same products
and overlaying it on top
of that research method.
So now we have a
multi-method design,
where we're both doing sort
of interviews, observations,
but we can look at objective
data trends for usage
across the entire time that
we're doing that field studies.
And so that's a very exciting
thing for us, not only
at Pearson, but I think
in education overall.
There's all these
new types of data
that we've never
had in the past,
and you can imagine what happens
to usage of a particular,
let's say product or asset
or interactive thing,
across an entire semester
of a school year, right?
It's very difficult
to get that when
you're observing for a week,
but if we can collect that data
across a whole semester,
across a whole year,
it gives us insights again
to improve our products,
to make them more effective, and
make them better for students
and better for teachers.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's awesome.
I'm so happy that you're
sharing your methods with us,
that Pandas now has
a BigQuery connector.
I know you're just
getting started with it.
The community will
grow around it.
You will stay part of
the Pandas community?
SEAN SCHAEFER: Yes,
we definitely will be.
COLLIN SELLMAN:
Yeah, we hope so.
And for those that maybe
haven't heard of Pandas,
there's a great book called
"Python for Data and Analytics"
that West McKinney, who was
one of the major contributors
to Pandas, has written,
and I really recommend it.
It's a really great,
accessible book
to get you started with Pandas.
It doesn't have the
read_gbq method yet,
but you can learn about
that on the website.
But it really gives you a lot of
the great things the Pandas can
do with time series data, a
lot of really powerful things
there, and all the
different types of ways
that you can analyze data
using Python and Pandas.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's awesome.
Thank you for coming today.
Thank you Jacob, thank you
Sean, thank you Collin.
I hope to stay working with you.
COLLIN SELLMAN: Likewise,
it's been great.
Thanks for having us.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank you
everybody for tuning in.
Try BigQuery out, try
these methods out.
There are really some
amazing questions
that no one has asked before
and you are able to ask now.
Until the next time.